no one celebrates easter like filipinos
we go ham on easter
action junior eat something
it's time for me to do some stunts
is there any way you can just let us go
with a warning you were doing 70 in a 40
in a subaru i was on tour and i just
kept saying man i would love to do like
a friday style movie all the chaos all
the comedy all the love all the tears
and i started thinking to myself
what is that day and i was just like
easter easter sunday is like the
filipino super bowl my whole goal is to
have my mom's voice to be heard and
you're gonna relate because there's no
difference from my mom and your mom it's
just my mom has an accent joseph you
could have been a lawyer if you only
applied yourself couldn't believe it we
got tia lou and tiffany to be in this
movie congratulations on your big new tv
show tia she's 40 years in the game
right now and she's like this is the
first time ever i play the filipino and
then lou tells us his story you are
filipino right you were so great in la
bamba i could have sworn you're a
mexican have filipino half scots irish
but did mel gibson put me in braveheart
oh no and tiffany and i the way back
friends for life for life you know me
and your daddy we used to be real
intimate back in the day oh yeah yeah i
could have been your mom
it's my family it's everyone's family
it's just love it's chaos singing it's
dancing it's crying it's everything that
a family goes through all in one day
that's what easter sunday is all about
you